Martis with us in New York hey Marty
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve
what's up I'm gonna show been binging on
your podcast for a couple weeks I've
been lovin it okay um I have a quick
question for you um should i my lease is
on my car is up this month the hotel shy
lease a car or should I buy a reliable
used car but so these payments for the
car would be relatively cheap it's not
you know not a BMW you know like a $200
all everything you know roll Ventura no
no fees do at the beginning at the
signing Johnson what would you do III
really appreciate you calling and asking
the question is because it's a great
question that's on the top of a lot of
people's minds so here's the thing
leasing a car is an alternative form of
financing a car so if we were to take
the actual lease payments on the average
lease in your case $200 right and you
were to take the buyout at the end of
the lease those are the two financial
numbers you would need to put into a
financial calculator and then you
compare that with the sticker price of
the car the manufacturer's suggested
retail right you would find that this
money that you're borrowing that you're
renting is costing you on average 14.2%
that's the average lease yield now Elyse
is not technically borrowing money so
the Federal Trade Commission does not
make them reveal that to you or this a
car loan you'd get this little
ridiculous federal piece of paper that
shows you exactly what your money is
costing you what your annual percentage
rate is and if they were to do that on a
lease you would find the typical lease
it varies but I'm saying the typical
lease is around 14% and I've analyzed
these things for 30 years and looked at
them and run them through the financial
calculator Smart Money Magazine did a
full expose on them consumer reports
that a full expose consumer reports
actual comment at the end of their full
piece of
research on a whole bunch of leases that
have much more thorough job than I have
done said the moat their quote at the
end of the article was the most
expensive way to operate a vehicle is to
lease it and this is even if I'm gonna
finance a car in a five-year payment
plan or something like that well number
one I'm gonna tell you don't finance
anything and if you did coming out of
this I'm going to tell you to we'll come
back to that in just a second but I'm
gonna tell you to pay it off as soon as
possible not for five years because
that's the second part of our equation
and then we'll come back in all the
years I've been working with people who
started from nothing and built wealth we
call them everyday millionaires they
started from nothing and became wealthy
they typically say one of the things
that turned their life around was they
started asking when they started looking
at purchasing something they started
asking how much so rich people ask how
much broke people and I've been both
brother okay broke people ask how much
down and how much a month in this entire
conversation all you've talked about is
how much down how much a month so you
got to stop that dude you got to start
asking how much because that's the part
that kills you how much down how much a
month says I'm gonna be in debt to the
man and I'm gonna pay payments to the
man the rest of my life and I'm gonna be
normal which sucks and you don't want to
do that so we we broke down the lease is
a bad idea how much looking at analyzing
these decisions based on your monthly
rather than the total purchase price is
a bad idea now let's back up and look at
your particular situation how old are
you and what do you make okay thirty
years old and I'm thinking about say 125
between being my life oh good for you
great congratulations that and so much
money will you have so much money do you
have saved not counting retirement so
I'd say 25 25 thousand if like a little
emergency fund or little miscellaneous
savings account with twenty five
thousand bucks in it yeah okay and the
used car you were considering purchasing
was
how expensive what was the price on it
I'm looking round by the phase fourteen
fifteen thousand okay just riding you I
would just write a check and right out
of your twenty five and then you ready
check right now when you get ready to
turn the lease in right when you get
ready to do that you got twenty five
thousand dollars by a fifteen thousand
dollar car that leaves you ten thousand
dollars then your next order of business
in your budgeting and financial plan is
to rebuild your emergency fund because
25 is probably about the right amount
and I want you to get it back up there
do you have any other debts not counting
this car situation I'm on the student
loan but that's you know my parents are
taking care of that so is it in your
name was Ernest relatively well it's in
my name how much is this relatively low
my whole schooling was like 35 grand how
much my parents how much is in your name
in student loan debt I don't even know
but I would go ten fifteen thousand okay
well I would love for you to go get that
rid of that as soon as you can - okay
and so would your mom and dad by the way
you make a hundred twenty five thousand
a year
I appreciate that they're taking care of
it if they're a day late it dings your
credit if they're a month late it starts
to step on your credit if they get in a
real trouble
it's your loan you're gonna end up
paying that's the legality of it and so
if I were you I would want that cleared
out of my name as soon as possible hey
men appreciate having you as a new
listener